we're going to begin with this we are
one day away from a pivotal hearing on
the sexual assault allegations against
Supreme Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh
but this morning a fixture in America's
living rooms for nearly half a century
is waking up in prison because of his
sexual misconduct a judge sentenced Bill
Cosby to 3 to 10 years for drugging and
sexually assaulting and you're a
constant at his home nearly 15 years ago
more than 60 other women have also
accused Cosby of sexually assaulting
them the 81 year old once known as
America's dad will have to register as a
sex offender for the remainder of his
days his spokesman called the trial
racist and sexist and says Cosby will
appeal mr. Cosby's the fist team is
preparing a motion to address mr. steel
use of falsified evidence mr. Cosby
clearly has been denied his right to a
fair trial
these in justices must be corrected
immediately
Jericka Duncan spoke with one of the
prosecutors in an interview you'll see
first on CBS this morning she's at the
Montgomery County Courthouse in
Norristown Pennsylvania
Jericka good morning good morning it's
the big story here in Bill Cosby's
hometown a picture of him on one of the
papers his mugshot behind bars you know
all of this started 33 months ago right
here in Montgomery County criminal
charges two trials later the result the
District Attorney's Office was hoping
for has been realized Bill Cosby was
taken away in handcuffs leaving a
courtroom yesterday only people by his
side his publicist and sheriff's
deputies we spoke to two women who
testified at that second trial after the
sentencing did you ever really believe
that this day would come
I can't say I believed what I did
as I hoped and I fought and I tried to
do everything that was right to support
him going to jail I just wanted to see
him like that because my chains are
broken now now it's time to see him with
someone in her Victim Impact Statement
Andrea Constance said when the sexual
assault happened I was a young woman
brimming with confidence
Bill Cosby took my beautiful healthy
young spirit and crushed it now we got a
chance to speak to the 35 year old
prosecutor Kristen ffedith who played a
very instrumental role in this case she
was the one who actually went to Toronto
three years ago to interview Andrea
concen when the district attorney's
office was considering reopening this
case now early on in the investigation
fed and pressed the DA's office to
charge Cosby and if not for her the DA
said his team would not have gotten the
conviction as a young lawyer and to be
now connected to this historic case for
the rest of your life what was that like
to hear the district attorney give you
the credit it was very touching it meant
a lot to me because I have two young
boys I have a wonderful husband I have a
wonderful family but I put in a lot of
sacrifice as well for this case and with
all of my sex cases I don't recommend
charges lightly because I understand the
stigma that can attach when someone is
charged with a crime as serious as
sexual assault do you think it means
even more because in 2015 when Cosby was
charged
there was no me to movement sure I think
that the me2 movement is a very powerful
movement because when you have a victim
of crime and I think it's important to
just go back to victims of crime they're
humiliated they are ashamed they are
embarrassed that isolation that feeling
that they won't be believed and
unfortunately you saw it with andrea
constand you see it with the Kavanaugh
accusers what was the first thing Andrea
said to you after the sentence was read
I believe I asked her a happy with the
sentence
and she said yes and that meant the
world to me do you consider yourself a
trailblazer I believed that I was part
of a very important case and I had a
team of people to help me I had as I
have in many cases a very strong and
courageous victim one of Cosby's
accusers said people shouldn't feel
sorry for the 81 year old because of his
age because she said quote he didn't
consider my age when he took my
innocence
legal experts that I spoke to said that
it will likely be at least a year that
Cosby spends in prison before he sees
any action on an appeal Gail and I write
Eureka thank you very much